comme d'habitude cet exercice de travail
de pied on cherche à rebondir sur
l'avant du pied on peut ce paletot
rebondir se préparer comme d'habitude
même pendant les fêtes de noël et alors
que les températures avoisinent les 0°
ce mercredi matin 28 décembre ils sont
une vingtaine de jeunes de l'union
athlétique de versailles a bravé le
froid
au programme de la séance des exercices
de mise en jambes et des courses
fractionnées on en profite pour pour
s'entraîner on va presque dire deux fois
plus en quantité en intensité
pourquoi parce que à côté ils n'ont pas
école
donc il ya moins de fatigue avec les
devoirs le stress des contrôles des
examens donc ils peuvent un peu plus se
reposer ce qu'on se concentrer
uniquement finalement sur sur l'arc la
clé c'est sur leurs entraînements du
lundi au vendredi de 10h à 12h30 ce
stage de fin d'année a pour but de
préparer les futures échéances avec des
compétitions dès le mois de janvier
si vous coupez les deux semaines pour
les vacances ou même une semaine le
temps que vous coupez c'est le temps qui
sera nécessaire à la rentrée pour se
remettre en route
sauf qu'aujourd'hui si vous coupez deux
semaines sachant que l'échéance
importante à la rentrée elle est dès la
première semaine
vous savez déjà que vous pouvez pas être
compétitif pour être performant sur sur
ce sur ce cross alors que la plupart de
leurs amis sont sous la couette
lorsqu'il commence l'entraînement ces
jeunes âgés de 14 à 17 ans restent fixés
sur leurs objectifs
au début c'est un peu compliqué quand on
reprend tout comme c'est un stage donc
la liste un peu compliqué mais
maintenant je me dis que si je fais ça
c'est pour comme ça j'ai un but c'est de
faire un podium sinon ce serait
compliqué aussi devenir comme il fait
froid c'est un peu compliqué parfois
c'est une violence aussi après il ya
restants il paye pas et on est on est
pas content et on sait maintenant que
travailler pour la suite
le premier rendez vous de la saison pour
l'union athlétique de versailles est
prévue le 8 janvier à sartrouville deux
semaines plus tard la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines sera le cadre
d'accueil du championnat de france unss